Pope Francis spoke to about 60 000 young
people in a stadium in Kinshasa it's the
first time a pope has come to Democratic
Republic of Congo in nearly 40 years he
said the foreign plundering of Congo's
minerals is fueling conflict and must
stop
when I deplor is the war continues in
DRC in the east of the country you see
what happens in Ukraine and all the
International Community mobilizes but
what happens in DRC is much worse
the Roman Catholic Church is one of the
most powerful institutions in Congo
millions of people depend on it for
health care and education people here
are trying to get
you see the pope kinshasa's many Street
Traders are selling drinks and food and
flags and Pope t-shirts but not
everybody here is happy with the Pope
these activists say Pope Francis has
failed to stop Sexual Violence by clergy
Benjamin kiboko says he was repeatedly
raped by a Belgian priest for years when
he was a boy in a remote Village he says
years later the Catholic church in
Belgium paid him 25
000 compensation but the priest went on
to work in an orphanage the mud is never
closed because the abuse are still
working
they promise to deflog them from the
military but they are still working
so there is no justice yet
the campaigners say the Catholic Church
continues to protect sexual abusers and
to bury complaints of abuse including
the recent case of a 13 year old girl in
Congo who says she was raped by a priest
and if he doesn't act he's contributing
to the continued abuse of children we
have strong reasons to believe that when
abuse story comes out in Africa it'll be
worse than it was in in the West in the
US and Western Europe but until the pope
takes measures to hold his Bishops and
face accountable we're never going to
know that story
[Music]
four years ago Pope Francis introduced
rules to stop sexual abuse and cover-ups
the campaigners say they're not followed
in the developing world and most of
those abused here in Congo still suffer
in silence Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera
Kinshasa Democratic Republic of Congo